can jump forward to give a check
and that's what's happened because he
just lost his pawn yeah he hasn't looked
he just leaned back and put his hand on
his head on he just lost a pawn for free
suddenly no more easy win this is a
fight
how he just gave away a pawn for free
walked into a check it was the clock i
think that played a big factor there
black's king will step back
white's remaining pawn is under fire as
well this one
wow this is so hard because the the
knight is actually separated far away
from the king
this is a very nice move i mean you've
got to
yeah like you say you've been away the
way you've got to try to win this one is
keep the black knight away from the
black king right it gets back
black knight is coming back it's going
to use its pawns to protect it and
suddenly who's playing for the win
you you you can certainly push for the
win here uh if you can just get that
knight of course it's going to be
winning for white
but here it comes back towards king this
is what magnus needs to do and i think
he's going to do it if he gets the black
knight next to the black king it's a
pretty simple technical draw and i think
he's done that now he's got the black
knight next to the king there you go
this is a draw the king could just look
after the knight now you can see relax
their body language as well uh magnus is
obviously very confident in this
position um keep the knight near the
king the king can defend the night
you've got to watch out for obviously
the obvious blunders but
it's uh he he's held it
remarkably the problem here the reason
white can't win is you can never get
your king opposite the black king
black's knight will always check your
way as soon as you go one way with the
white king the black king will go the
other way and yeah the black knight is
just a perfect defender look how it
blocks the checks stopping the white
king from moving and there we go it's a
draw and magnus takes today's match wow
what a fight between these two a
handshake and it's over minus takes the
two points he wins the match